>>Teacher: Put your hand up if someone
in your family comes from somewhere else
in the world and has
come to live in London.
Could you turn to the person next to you
and have a discussion
about this talking point?
>>Student: I think Stratford
is a better place to live
because they're not against
anyone and it's--
>>Student: Can I just clarify you?
What do you mean by, like, against?
>>Teacher: Oracy is the
keystone to everything
that happens in the curriculum.
There are such high expectations
for talk
and it does really make a difference
in the children, how articulate
and how confident they are.
>>Peter: The vision of School Twenty-One
is to prepare young people for the world
that they're going to go into
in the twenty-first century.
I think one of the biggest barriers to
the students we serve really getting
on in life is lack of
good communication skills.
We need to elevate speaking to the
same level as reading and writing.
>>Milo: So we have a vote.
>>What makes me enjoy talking the most
is that everybody's listening to you
and you're like, part of the world,
and you feel respected and important.
>>Alexia: When I'm talking, they're
listening to what I'm saying,
and sometimes they give me questions,
or then maybe I give them questions.
>>Beccy: Every child within this school
is expected to speak in every lesson,
in every opportunity throughout their
school day, and try and create lots
of different context for young people
to hone their skills as speakers.
>>Amy: So what I want us to do now is
have a discussion about different kinds
of culture, and I want
us to discuss this:
some cultures are better than others.
>>I think every teacher, if you say to
them, "Do you talk in your classroom?"
of course they're talking
in their classroom.
But what's different here
is the deliberateness of it.
>>Beccy: Every teacher needs
to have that toolkit of things
that they can draw on to bring
effective talk into their practices.
>>Amy: We've done a lot of
work introducing sentence stems
that children can use for different
situations, so for agreeing
with somebody, for disagreeing politely
with someone, for challenging someone.
>>And while we're doing that, I want
you to make sure that you're using some
of the sentence stems, so you might say,
linking to someone's points or build
on something that somebody has said.
>>Student: Building on there,
I agree, because maybe--
>>Amy: The thing that's
had the biggest impact
on my practice is probably
discussion guidelines.
>>We are going to be discussing
why beliefs were important,
or why they weren't important
in ancient Greece.
Could anybody remind me about
any of our discussion guidelines?
>>Student: One of them is when
someone's not contributing,
you have to invite them by asking
them a question, or saying their name.
>>Amy: Excellent, why
would you do that, Aram?
>>Student: Then everyone has an idea.
>>Amy: Everyone gets to
share their idea, don't they.
Well done.
>>So discussion guidelines were created
in conjunction with the children.
These are the five of six key things
that we think make a
really good discussion.
I've been able to take a step back
and I think that the children take
on a larger role within the classroom.
>>Student: I think it
should be Ares and Athena,
because they're both the god of war.
>>Student: Yeah, but to challenge you
Debar, there are lots of fishermen--
>>Amy: So another key way of
promoting oracy in the classroom is
to think carefully about
the groupings that you use.
So whether you're getting
them to talk in pairs
or in trios, or in larger groups.
>>Beccy: Sometimes it's best
to have students in threes.
Sometimes we look at how they can stand
in the traverse, opposite each other.
Each of those different
groupings enables a different type
of conversation.
>>Students: If you see inside them,
we're all human beings
and we're all people.
>>Beccy: Our oracy program
is comprehensive.
It has to be seen in maths
and science and those subjects
that traditionally haven't
had a talk focus.
>>Kate: There are twenty-four
cookies altogether.
>>Students: There are
twenty-four cookies altogether.
>>Kate: There are three children.
>>Students: There are three children.
>>Kate: Alright, let's see if Alexia--
>>I would say that I'd always encouraged
talk in my maths lessons before,
but what's changed is that I really
plan very carefully for talk,
and also I structure the
talk very explicitly.
>>Okay, so we're going to
go and do our talk task.
>>The talk task, they get to practice
what they've done in the new learning,
and they're talking through
what they're doing.
So it's about developing their
vocabulary and language of explanation.
>>Alexia: We were talking
about fractions.
We'd done four circles,
and then we needed
to share twenty-four in each group.
>>One, two, three, four, fix, six.
Your turn.
>>We were using sentences to help us.
>>Students: Twenty-four shared equally
between four children is equal to six.
>>Alexia: Let's do another one.
>>Peter: There are lots of
different reasons why we get students
who may not feel it's
almost their place to speak.
So for all those reasons,
oracy is an issue of equality,
of equity, of social mobility.
>>Teacher: Wow, I heard some pretty
amazing discussions going on just now.
So let's get some feedback
from some groups.
>>Beccy: Because of the focus on oracy,
we've seen our students become
much more confident in their ideas.
By creating the context and the
opportunities for them to speak,
they've just flown, and become
eloquent, engaging speakers.
>>Teacher: Hayden?
>>Hayden: We came to a decision and
said that we disagree with the text.
Everyone is unique, everyone's the same,
but they do their things
in different ways.